hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play slender
the arrival okay there was a most recent
update in version 1.3 that added a new
area to the game so I am actually very
interested in seeing it I don't really
know anything about it people just told
me that there was an update to this game
and I knew that I had to get into it
right away it is called Genesis so let's
go I'm guessing it leave or picks up
where the other part left off oh hello
it's war oh oh is this what I think it
is could this be
I think it is the Genesis obviously
means the origin end oh my goodness they
changed the big red dildo it is like is
like the original slender the eight
pages remade in slender the arrival
wicked cool because I've never actually
beaten slender the eight pages so why
why wasn't announced very much okay is
there anything on the bedroom got it got
it off the big red build oh okay I'm
gonna go my route that I ran before that
never has worked for me but I'm gonna
try it anyway to see if I can get it so
what I know is I hit the red dildo I go
up to the center of the map into the
middle area that way I can you know what
I'm gonna start running right away no I
shouldn't start running right away there
was one game sundry game that I was
playing that the mechanics weren't quite
with the running and the similar thingy
and the thong I don't know don't judge
me I don't know what I'm talking about
half the time I don't even know where I
am
so oh look is the familiar chair it's so
much more detailed it looks phenomenal
yes I can see the bricks man this is
something else okay anyway enough enough
stroking of egos about how great this is
I might miss a page easily here because
the pages seem much smaller than I'm
used to and they're quite hard to see
man this is a pretty faithful recreation
though
case you didn't know obviously they're
made by the same people so this is just
only natural that they would have this
in slender the arrival I'm not seeing a
page in here unless I've missed it don't
think I have I don't think you think a
thought but apparently there is not okay
so I wanted to do is go out here and
once we get it from here then we can
take the route to the rock formation and
then continue on our loop hello where
are you are you at slim be man I don't
see you so we continue down south ish
this I think we're now playing as Kate
to immediately hit the rock formations
which are right here someone that treat
seems like that Bart got blown off
Slenderman was doing some strange to
that tree over there and we are not
getting very lucky on these pages where
the hell are they unless they've added
something else which I bet they they
might have where are you Slendy I don't
even see you I don't see a page here
well douchenozzle
oh there he is hey whoa you are moving I
stopped at don't think you can fool me
Slenderman I saw exactly what you were
doing you're trying to sneak up on me
well not today mr. douche okay
now sign a man's being his own stupid
self but we are gonna continue in
persevere it's actually really nice
because things look different like the
woods actually look relatively different
to each other so it's actually easier to
identify where I am and where I'm going
and if there's not a page on here I'm
gonna be very ya got it three of eight
okay where is he where is he
whoa that was new
get out of here Slendy okay so Barry is
okay just need to keep my eye on him so
that I know where I'm going so now I go
into the pillars of poo which have been
thoroughly changed nothing's the same as
it used to be no way these are still
pillars of poo
who is that a page I see yes sir okay
four of eight doing great now we just
need to go forward this way see I've
never managed to beat it before but I
still know the strategy to get it you
got to get the centre because you don't
want to be getting a page out of the
centre and then you got a loop around
the outskirts of the entire place see
now we got five of eight we're doing
fantastically so I need to go back up
here to get on the path outside of there
too because the tube leads in it points
into the centre of the map but there is
also something that you can hi where are
you where are you now see you all areas
what what happened Oh black what the
hell my framerate just tanked what the
hell just happened
hello am I still on vocab super
challenge mode I'm now playing blind
what this is bull
well other than being what the that's
new
haha Slendy hi so yeah that was Kate
that I was playing it and I don't know
what the hell just happened there but
that was dumb I was on my way to win
alright let's give this another go
since Lindy has plans for me apparently
nope it's not working anyway well that's
the professional game breaker that I am
apparently I can't even I can't even get
into the game anymore because it is
thoroughly broken itself I have a bad
habit if you don't know me of breaking
whatever game like get into it no matter
what I do no matter how hard I try I can
break the game and I've broken the game
many many many many many times and this
one but you get to just do it right
I haven't beat it I will never beat the
original sunder the eight pages no
matter how hard I try I don't know
what's going on but you got the gist of
it so there is some of the eight pages
recreated in slender the arrival now you
do play as Kate and as you can see
slightly man is now hanging out in front
of me I just want to see there's
something different now I've had nothing
nothing different right just want to
check land for sale with that sign
always there we'll just dump always here
with that sky okay alright enough of
that we're all done here so thank you
all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I'll see you in the
next video
under control
I'll come back later I'm not kidding